I'm the CTO Tokyo gay design I'm doing
web application development since the
days of HTML 1.0 Perl 3 and CGI when web
pages were first painted on cave walls
and over the years I've learned some
things I will try to share with you in
the next 10 minutes and that pokeo key
design we do work in WordPress we also
do work in in Ruby on Rails and those
are two very different platforms using
two very different languages but there
are techniques and approaches that
really apply across languages across
platforms and really that's what I'm
here to talk to you about
so that might sound nice clean code but
I have a deadline I don't have time for
clean code so you know we run into this
all the time we're into deadline
pressure our project managers our
clients are telling us that we've got to
get this done by Friday you're working
long hours and the common outcome of
this is the big ball of mud code the
fast and dirty code to get something
done
so we're asked to go faster but what
happens is we actually end up going
slower there are more bugs we have to go
back and fix them we're finding needles
in haystacks getting the work done
actually takes longer than if we adjust
written clean code to begin with slowly
the idea here is a an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure so
how do we know this there's actually
been studies that have done studies that
have been done watching actually
programmers work how are they spending
their time and the ratio of times and
reading code versus writing is well over
ten to one people are actually spending
most of their time scrolling up and down
in a file looking for something no it's
not they're open another file oh it's
not there either
what am i where is this thing I'm trying
to fix the actual time you spend typing
is a lot less than the time you spend
just looking around so if you take the
time to make your code easy to read you
will be make the code you will make the
code easier to write this is a great
quote from Douglas Crockford
some of the people create a JSON he said
we like to think we spend our time power
typing but we actually spend most of our
time staring into the abyss and this is
what I was just talking about spend a
lot of our time fighting the messy code
so with that as an explanation as to why
it's important here are 10 quick tips
for making your code clean number one
you are responsible for the quality of
your code not your client not your boss
if you think about other professions
doctors lawyers accountants they all
have professional standards that they
adhere to you don't go to the doctor and
say you know what doc I'm in alright
want to just skip washing your hands you
know go to your account and say why
don't you just skip the double-entry
bookkeeping why are you bothering with
that let's let's go you know we have
certain respect for people in these
professions and respect how they work so
if we want to be treated as
professionals we have to act like
professionals we have to be advocates
for the quality of the code that we
write and advocate for doing it the
right way and not accept the option to
do it the wrong way to where a young
feel them to me that's very exciting to
be part of defining what these
professional standards are and it's up
to us to create them not our clients not
our project managers that's number one
number two when you're writing your code
use meaningful names so for example with
variables this is an example of a
variable name that's not very good
dollar sign gee what does that mean by
itself you've got a little comment it
tells you what it does but once you
start getting to the code you know
looking at all these variables with all
these cryptic names the mental
translating you have to do going back
and forth between some cryptic little
symbol and its actual meaning starts to
get in your way in the way of actually
understanding the work that you're
trying to do so here are some better
names that actually tell you what the
variable does Grady Booch the former
chief scientists at IBM said that clean
code should read like well-written prose
so if you look at variable names like
this the variable names
nouns in your prose number three we get
to our verbs writing code that expresses
intent these are our functions our
methods if you're objecting only in
programming however if you can see the
code on the screen merits by a little
small but the idea here is that we have
method names just like our variable
names that clearly explain what it's for
and as you read the code you can sort of
you know understand what it's doing and
I'm not even giving you any context you
don't know what class this came from but
you can read it and sort of get a sense
of what's going on and you can do that
without something there's something
that's not here and the thing that's not
here is comments so this will be kind of
a controversial comment on comments but
comments are often lies waiting to
happen
code should speak for itself whenever
possible so what I mean by this often we
write comments because the code the
intention of the code isn't clear so we
think okay let's write a comment that
will explain it but when you create the
comment you've now written something
else that you have to maintain in
addition to the code and what often
happens once people are working on a
project they come in they fix a bug they
update the code maybe they don't notice
the comment now the comments wrong and
now it's a lie and it's going to take a
future developer down the wrong path and
they come down and look at this so I'm
not saying never write comments often
they are important for example if you're
dealing with like a third party API you
need to explain some behavior you know
you can't necessarily do that in the
code so there are good cases for writing
comments I'm not saying never use them
what I am saying is when you're about to
write a comment step back and think for
a moment and think you know can I write
code that expresses itself a little
better and then maybe I don't have to
write a comment number five the Boy
Scout rule in the case of code when we
talk about the Boy Scout rule we mean
leave the code better than you found it
the Boy Scouts leave the campsite better
than you found it
so not only am i saying should you write
clean code but if you're going in or
hang on some existing code to take your
new stuff write it well but take a few
minutes and look at the surrounding code
can I improve a variable name can I
break up a method is it that's too big
so instead of the common scenario of bit
rot where code just gets Messier and
Messier over time we can instead have
koba gets cleaner including air over
time this is possible and I've worked
with people who've done it and it's a
great way to work number six a single
responsibility principle this is a one
of five principles coined by ax Bob
Martin who actually wrote a book called
clean code and many of the ideas my talk
come from they're so single
responsibility principle this is the
idea when we're talking about say a
function or method that it does one
thing it does it well and it does it
only so what do we mean by that a good
way to think about it is if you're
passing four or five arguments to a
function that's probably doing more than
one thing if you think about all those
variables you're passing in you're now
sort of creating a matrix of possible
outcomes that can be quite large and it
can be hard to debug if there's problems
with it because there's so many things
going on inside it so that's a good way
of getting familiar with this principle
when it comes to functions and methods
with classes if you're doing
object-oriented programming what you're
looking for is what's called
cohesiveness and the idea there is are
most of the methods in the class using
most of the properties that all sort of
hangs together if you've got one subset
of methods using half the properties and
another subset of methods using the
other half you're probably doing more
than one thing in that class maybe it
actually needs to be two classes so they
each have a clear conceptual
responsibility and when you come to work
on the coding and it's clear what
they're doing when they have one
responsibility as opposed to many number
seven right
if you saw Carl Alexander's talk
yesterday he did an excellent
presentation on this wood much deeper
dive that I can take in 30 seconds but
there's really two kinds of tests one
type is called integration tests which
actually test the functionality you know
how a user will experience your code and
these have saved me so many times where
I've changed something over here and
I've run the test and found what do you
know it broke something over there and
it's much better than I find it with my
tests and an angry customer finding it
two weeks from now and they're also unit
tests which test your functionality and
isolation intensive and development is a
great way to do this where you first
come up with a test and then write your
code to pass the test and it leads to
better design I am running out of time
I'm going to move a little faster I'm
going to skip membrane and hit you with
number nine independent architecture why
am i subjecting you to this awful image
this is a quote from Bob Martin says
it's software architectures are
structures that support the use cases of
the system frameworks are tools to be
used not architectures to be conformed
to so what's he talking about here you
can make a wordpress as a framework so
you can say WordPress is a tool to be
used not an architecture to be conformed
to the idea here is that they're good
practices that can be applied across
different frameworks and languages so
for example WordPress plugins that I've
written it's very clear from looking at
the files and the variable names what
functionality this plug-in implements
and I could even with a few changes take
it outside of WordPress and use it my
connections to WordPress aren't any
greater than they need to be so the use
cases are clear in the plug-in as
opposed to so it's not sort of yelling
at you that is WordPress plug-in is
yelling at you that it's a photo display
or something like that
number 10 practice practice practice
musicians don't only play when they're
on stage in front of an audience
and really the same thing applies to
programming Duke Okada's go to
contributor day learn new techniques
when you're not performing for client
who's paying you and that's a way you
can really improve your skills and I am
done thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]